bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors qu'est ce qui change
entre cette médiation de la cedeao et la
précédente
bonjour cette mutation est la suite
logique de la mission de du président
goodluck johnatan c'est dit c'était
juste
cette conférence le sommet avait pour
but de réitérer de propositions de la
mission présidente donc il n'y a rien de
nouveau comme on dit sous les tropiques
alors on revient au point de départ en
fait finalement l'opposition qui réclame
toujours le départ n'est président
ibrahim boubacar kéïta exactement je
pense que le la cedao en à travers cette
mission a quand même à radicaliser un
petit peu des positions des opposants
notamment du n 5 et l aspect ce que les
deux lors de la mission précédente
ils ont eu quand même assez des sept
partis qui étaient réclamés notamment la
démission du président ibrahim boubacar
keita
mais aujourd'hui avec les relations de
la cedao qui foulent du pied les de la
constitution malienne ceci amène à
radicaliser les positions des opposants
alors selon vous la cedeao n'a écouté
aucun point en tout cas aucune
revendication la part de l'opposition en
tout cas du mouvement m 5
naturellement elle a écouté mais est ce
qu'elle a entendu je pense qu'elle a
pris à la légère un petit peu le conflit
malien puisque c'était un réel conflit
et c'est surtout une crise
sociopolitique
aujourd'hui il s'agit pas d'un simple
contentieux électoral à la sortie des
élections législatives de de masse avait
2020 s'ils surtout une crise
sociopolitique et je pense que s'il
avait pris le temps d'analyser la scène
cette crise politique et socio politique
et elle n'aurait pas eu à proposer ce
genre de recommandations
ce que dira que les députés 31 députés
qui démissionnent
ce n'est pas inscrit dans la
constitution malienne alors si ses
députés refusent de démissionner qu'est
ce que la cedao en tant qu organisation
supranationale pourrait faire je doute
que le les lois de la cedao supplante la
constitution malienne alors à vous le
disiez la chrysomèle
ce n'est pas seulement contentieux
électoral on a quand même l'impression
que ce contentieux électoral un peu
exacerbé les tensions qui était déjà
existantes dans le pays
quels sont justement ces tensions ont
été seuls sont d'abord économiques
il ya la tension sécurité on l'a vu
depuis huit ans le malien en proie à une
occupation de 64,68 son territoire et le
présent et pour une fois car keita était
pour tous les maliens lors de son
premier mandat en tout cas l'homme de la
solution aujourd'hui malheureusement
avant son arrivée on avec eux une partie
du nord du mali qui est occupée par pas
une nébuleuse dia d'eau et un terroriste
et aujourd'hui on a le centre et on a
des attaques sporadiques parler par
endroits dans d'autres régions
donc aujourd'hui oui la crise et
économiques et les sécuritaires et il ya
cette crispation politique qui se
rajoute à cette crise
manifestement ce n'est pas la cedeao qui
va réussir à résoudre la crise qui selon
vous pourra jouer ce rôle comme j'ai
rappelé lors d'une de mes interviews la
solution allait mal et elle ne peut être
que malienne il faut qu'aujourd'hui le
président ibrahim boubacar keita montre
qu'il est le père de la nation qui tente
franchement la main à l'opposition et au
delà je dirais pas l'opposition à
l'ensemble des maliens
ce que c'est l'homme de la situation il
a une confiance des maladies
démocratiquement élu et aujourd'hui il
faut qu'ils comprennent que la solution
est entre ses mains et non dans les mâts
des négociateurs de la cedao il est
temps que le malien enfin se retrouvent
autour d'une table et se parler sans
intermédiaire c'est parler franchement
et trouver des solutions vidéo elle
enfin quand on sort de cette crise
peut-être un mot sur la nouvelle équipe
gouvernementale qui a été formé à ce
matin par abou cissé 6 membres
alors justement au gouvernement du cimt
a encore un précédent on s'attendait à
25 ministres comme le recommandent les
les résolutions du dialogue national
inclusif
on se retrouve à x y et c'est un
précédent pourquoi six peut-être ils
sont dix ministères régaliens pour gérer
les affaires courantes
mais il est temps vraiment d'ici la fin
de la semaine consciente avec un
gouvernement des 25 membres et qu'on
travaille enfin à une sortie de crise
la cedeao en tout cas donné à
jours pour que son plan de sortie de
crise soit accepter monsieur un beau ici
c'est merci d'avoir été en direct avec
nous sur rt france rappelle que vous
êtes un porte parole du conseil
supérieur de la diaspora malienne mer